deikun this is really important I've
brought you here because I have
questions for you okay
that's your it's about tick-tock Oh God
Reese Witherspoon and her son Deacon are
officially the cutest mother-son duo on
the internet witness tick tock
drop of moms out there what is it doc oh
my god okay so basically it's like a
short form video platform for a kids
social media yeah you heard that right
Deacon is teaching his mom the ways of
tick tock it's a stick he's talking no
reason to the to the top and Reese was
kind enough to film and post the entire
process and truly this is the type of
content we could only hope for people
like pick a song they like yeah and then
they like lip-sync the words yeah should
I be on tick tock sure really
we don't mean make a video for tick tock
okay yeah I'll be there
okay so Reese already gets all the cool
points but watching her dance just takes
it all to a whole new level Rolly Rolly
Rolly
and that's not even the coolest part
and it appears Rhys got real good a
tick-tock because she also shared this
[Music]
okay for those of you who are now loving
Deacon a little info he is the
fifteen-year-old son of Reece and her
ex-husband Orion Philippi
it would seem he's getting ready to get
his driver's license
he's only posted 12 times to Instagram
but has nearly a hundred and fifty
thousand followers impressive and of
course both Reece and Ryan have talked
to Ichi about their kids a whole Lots
over the years it's my kids for the best
gift in my life you know so lucky to
have them and they just made me happy
every day I don't think any parent gets
the ultimate cool card maybe once they
get into their 20s and their past the
teenage period I might become cool again
but I'm sure there's tons of stuff that
both reason I do that embarrass the kids
Ryan took a funnier approach back in
2017 when we asked about well just watch
is it fun for you to read all the
comments about how much they look like
you and Rhys I mean it's weird because
like isn't that obvious I always find
that such a weird thing like you know he
looks oh she looks exactly like her
mother who else is she like I wonder
sometimes like how they feel about it we
talk about it too but I think we've all
made peace with the fact that we're out
there in the public and that people are
gonna choose to kion
or whatever is interesting to them we
don't sit around talking about how much
we look an interesting point though cuz
I never thought about how it makes them
yeah cuz I see this sometimes I'm and I
feel like saying she has her own face
let her have her own face amazing that
is it for today for all the latest on
Rhys Ryan their kids and more keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]